and now we're in this hustle porn
culture where
if you're not if your output isn't like
insane and you're not grinding
24 7 and staying up all night and
pulling all-nighters and on your hustle
there's something wrong with you right
um so for the big story uh this week
rather than dive into the news headlines
i wanted to
seize an opportunity to do something a
little bit different
which is riff off a tweet that i saw the
other day from my friend steve magnus
steve's a
a former friend of the pod been on the
podcast twice
co-author with brad stallberg of a
couple great books he's an elite track
and field
coach former oregon project coach
a guy who's been outspoken against
doping and
alberto salazar specifically um
and he's just a source of wisdom on
twitter and he tweeted something that
that stuck with me
because it resonates with something i
think about a lot and his tweet goes
like this
there's a reason athletes have off
seasons
after intense stress you need time to
mentally and physically recover
periodize your life know when it's time
to grind and when you need to back off
and recover
i think it's a simple statement but i
think it's also profound this idea of
periodizing not just your training but
also
your life like everything has a season
yeah
and when i look at you adam i see
somebody who's trained for hard things
who's done hard things
but i'm not sure you've ever engaged in
a proper training protocol that involved
periodization we've
maybe periodization has come up from
time to time in former roll-ons but are
you familiar with the concept of
periodized training
no you're not at all
no no no but i haven't i haven't
you say i've done hard things i mean i
haven't trained for like
ultra distance events or even you know
like i mean but periodization
is a tried tried-and-true uh
approach to training for any it doesn't
have to be an ultra distance thing if
you're doing olympic triathlons if
you're training for a marathon if you're
training for
any kind of physical feat or
endurance challenge periodization is a
way of structuring
how you you create your schedule going
forward so
let's say you have a year to prepare for
a race a really big race it's on the
calendar
you look at the end date and you're like
okay that day's coming here i am 365
days beforehand how am i going to best
prepare so that on that race day i'm at
my
absolute peak to perform to my
capabilities and the way you do that is
you break
down your training into certain blocks
you have these this build phase and then
you back off and then you
go a little bit harder and then you back
off again and then you
increase again and then maybe you take
two weeks of really easy training like
you build in
periods of time mindfully that allow
your body to recover and this can happen
quarterly it can happen monthly it
happens weekly
it happens daily so there's the macro
and the micro that gets built
into all of this so that
you are breaking your body down but not
blind to the fact that you've got to
allow your body to build itself back
up so that you can then approach your
training as a stronger fitter athlete
to take it you know to the next level to
break through certain plateaus
and knowing when to back off and how to
back off and for how long to back off
is both an art and a science yeah i've
had
my best years as an athlete my best
performances
when i've really taken periodization to
heart and
followed the direction of my coach chris
south when i was a swimmer
there was no periodization we just went
in and we hammered every single day
and then we hung you know all our hopes
on a two-week taper at the end of the
season
and just prayed that it all worked out
sometimes it did sometimes it didn't but
you were that was
early early this is like 80s right like
that's what they did that right
exactly it's all about but now it's like
understanding
how how hard you can push before you tip
into overtraining and knowing when to
back off the gas
and allowing your body to recover
knowing how long you need
for your body to bounce back and what
kind of training you're doing
during those those sort of easier
intervals of time
really becomes this incredible lever for
growth
and and performance breakthroughs so how
would you
like if if you're training for catalina
i'm not i'm most likely not doing the
full distance catalina because i just
don't
i can't commit to the time it's going to
take to train for it with a young
young one but i am going to do the
sprint which is 15k
so how would you periodize that like
when would you start and
how would you periodize well first i
would break up the period of time into
like three phases
the first phase would be a endurance
building
like base building period where you're
just working on your
foundation and you're getting a lot of
zone two work in
and getting acclimated to spending a lot
of time
swimming and running so that your body
kind of knows what that feels like
you're giving your tendons and your
ligaments the opportunity to
adapt not just your lungs in your heart
but all of your muscles in your body
to figure out like how to sustain itself
over long periods of time so that phase
would be a slow progressive build of
going longer and longer and longer
mostly in the zone two phase but within
that block
you're gonna do a little maybe like a
two week build and then you're gonna
have four days that are gonna be pretty
easy or maybe a week that's pretty easy
where you're still training
but the gas isn't all the way pressed
down right
you're you're backing off so that during
that trip
that that week of training your body's
getting you're allowing your body to
recover and get stronger and then that
would be followed by an
another sub-block within the base
building block
of going a little bit longer than you
did in that initial block
to push through to the next barrier and
you just repeat rinse and repeat rinse
and repeat
and pay attention to how your body is
recovering during those
off periods so that you can better
calibrate
what those rest weeks look like and then
within each week
you have a rest day right so and then
within each day
you know you have when are you training
and what are you doing in between
in between your training sessions so
periodization works
at every level from yearly to monthly to
you know
weekly to daily then your second phase
would be
more of a strength and speed building
phase where you're going to be doing
more tempo work interspersed with
continuing to increase your volume over
zone two but
you're gonna choose moments where you're
gonna do you're you're gonna have really
hard
kind of um zone three zone four zone
five efforts
in there to get used to the idea
that you experience when you're doing a
swim run which is that you're always
changing gears
right you're ramping up your heart rate
it's coming back down it's going but
you're like
it's not like an iron man or a marathon
where you get into
you rev up to a certain speed and you
hold it as long as you can swim run
you're constantly switching back and
forth so it would be more
focused on getting your heart and your
lungs and your muscles acclimated to
heart rate spikes and getting fit enough
so that
your heart rate comes back down pretty
expeditiously right
the third phase would would be race
specific
then you're going to start sort of
training in the spirit of what the race
is and trying to
mimic what that experience is like six
week blocks usually well it depends on
how much time you have
you know what i mean like you can i mean
we could spend four hours trying to
figure out exactly
what to do and this is an ideal
situation this isn't necessarily
you know the the protocol for the
time-crunched
dad of a baby who only has you know
who's not going to be able to train
every single day but
basically i just want to lay that out in
the most general terms
to help people understand what
periodization looks like
can we build in a period for me to hunch
over my computer and type with two
fingers
yes okay there's room for all of it
that's what i do between
training sessions but i think the
broader point here and and why i wanted
to talk about this
um you know given that i've learned a
lot about the
the wisdom of periodizing endurance
training is that it's so applicable
in every other area of life and it goes
back to ancient wisdom
it's like eat with the seasons live by
the seasons why do i feel so
sluggish and tired in in the colder or
darker
months because you're hardwired for that
right like so like matt walker like that
how we were wired for when the sun went
down we all slept
for like that whole period of time right
like close to it and
and and and we've come so far from that
so that there's so many
kind of overlays right and now we're in
this hustle porn culture
where if you're not if your output isn't
like insane and you're not grinding
24 7 and staying up all night and
pulling all-nighters and on your hustle
there's something wrong with you right
such that when you have a fallow moment
and you want to rest or you're like i
just don't have it today you feel
guilty or you beat yourself up or you
have this sense that you're falling
behind
and i think that sensibility that
mentality that mindset
is anathema to long-term success
i think we need to understand that we're
all built
for periods of of great productivity
but if you want to sustain that over the
long period of time you have to
periodize
that you have to periodize your career
you have to periodize your creative
output you have to periodize
essentially everything that you do and
the more mindful
you can be to make sure that you're that
you're incorporating
fallow periods to coin bonnie choi's
article which we're going to talk about
um i think uh you know and it it's
for a lot of type a personalities it
doesn't feel it feels
indulgent right or selfish or
unproductive to do that
there's a guilt and there's a shame that
gets built into that that's driven by
cultural pressures that we need to
overcome and
as a 54 year old who's you know been
doing stuff for a long time
i can tell you you can't just be
cranking
all the time now you as a content
creator
you see burnout amidst content creators
because they can't sustain
the level of output that they're doing
and they either flame out or disappear
or they have to reinvent themselves
and create a way of contributing
their creativity in a manner that's more
sustainable
with with with lifestyle it's
interesting because like
two things came to my mind when you told
me you wanted to talk about this the
first is
when i was when lonely planet travel
guides were my primary
you know job when i was doing that it
was a period from 2007
to 2013 where i was gone
eight nine months a year and i would do
like three of these guides and that
that entailed long periods of travel
um usually in remote areas um
not always but usually um and then
come back either home or i'd rent a
place in the country
and long periods of just you know 12
hour days
10 hour days in the computer and then uh
and living in situ so i could make calls
if i didn't have all my research done i
knew
where i was um and so that
has a built-in kind of not fallow
because you're still hustling
but there is periodization in the
research gathering
and the writing and it was not it felt
natural and there is that still anytime
you're on a story
that like when writing when you're
trying to come up with something written
at the end of it versus what you're
doing with the mics
it's kind of your it's all one thing but
you're you're reporting
but that's different than the writing
where you can analyze and be kind of
create the distance in between and
organize it and
you know what you want to say versus the
the absorption which
and the second thing what that came to
mind was
bonnie's story which she published in
2019
which i i sent to you this morning and
um
because that's what she's talking about
is creating that space for absorption
as a as a creative person um so
that's it that's what that's immediately
where my mind went didn't go to
athletics at all for me because like
athletics are just kind of like
something for just to to keep my mind
right more than anything in my body
right but like i don't think of it in
terms of any sort of outcomes or
optimization and but i immediately went
to that point
like wow i don't really have what i used
to have there's no like
there's no longer that period of like
three months where i'm just traveling
and absorbing and three months of
writing like i don't have that anymore
two months of writing is what it used to
be or a month
yeah um so it's interesting and i do i
did like that rhythm there's something
real natural about it
yeah it comes in phases yeah right just
like if you're making a movie
you write the script by yourself or with
a friend or whatever
partner then you shoot the movie then
you edit the movie
then you market the movie all of those
are part and parcel of being a filmmaker
but they're all very different
disciplines that
i suspect for and and you know any every
filmmaker is going to excel in different
areas of those and maybe doesn't like
certain aspects of it but the switching
gears aspect of it
probably keeps them fresh
right in the same way that if you're a
triathlete you get to switch up
the different disciplines of sport that
you're pursuing for me people are always
like which one do you like the best and
it's like
i like that i get to change all the time
and it's not the same thing every single
day but i think
on top of that is
this idea of um you know to kind of
hearken to this idea of
of absorbing like that's where it gets
tricky for people like
look a lot of people they can't they
don't have the luxury of like i'm gonna
kick back and absorb
my life but if you're trying to express
something if you're a creative person
you have to live your life in order to
have something to say you can't just be
writing all the time because you're
going to run out of things to write
about if you're not
living right right so you have to live
your life
you have to have moments of absorption
no matter what your career path or how
busy your circumstances may be
what that looks like to you is gonna
depend on your circumstances and your
you know particularities of your life of
course
but i think just being mindful of that
and trying to find ways
even within your day in a given day
to ruminate or do nothing
and not feel guilty about it right right
there's that thing like
stand-up comics are people that just
don't like you know like like people
that don't like to wake up in the
morning you know
like are lazy like become stand-up
comics and it's like what does that guy
do
he just does nothing he wakes up at noon
and he like
goes and gets a sandwich and like
wanders around and then does
is like what is that person's you know
right what's driving that person but
they're overlooking the fact that the
brain is working all the time so there's
observation
there's synthesis there's absorption all
of those things are occurring
and we shouldn't be so quick to judge
how a certain
human operates also it's funny we say
he's doing nothing or she's doing
nothing
but they're being you know it's almost
like right but we're not allowed to just
be
that's the that's the broader point
right i mean there is a certain element
of
like i think you get to a certain point
you have to be able to afford to to be
but everyone has that like
i don't care what your job is there's
going to be
pressures to and we often fill that
space of doing nothing with
absorbing other people's content like
most people i think absorb it through
television or
netflix or youtube or whatever um
and you know myself included but uh
you know what bonnie is talking about
here is kind of an active not doing it's
it's it's
it's going to the park and people
watching it's reading it's she's not
really advocating
um she's not really advocating vegging
on the couch and watching television
no no no no what's she what she's saying
she's separating out the fellow
yeah yeah and and and acknowledging that
in this age of distraction
that it's transgressive to do this right
there's one quote that that i
noted that i wanted to read from the
piece which is called you're doing
something important when you aren't
doing anything we'll link it up in the
show notes but she says
protecting and practicing fallow time is
an act of resistance
it can make us feel out of step with
what the prevailing culture tells us the
24 7 hamster wheel of work
the constant accessibility and the
impatient press of social media
all hasten the anxiety over someone
else's judgment if you aren't visibly
producing
you aren't worthy in this context taking
time to lie dormant feels greedy
even wasteful and of course there are
often financial concerns
so yeah this this notion that it's
transgressive that it is an act of
resistance that you have to push back
against culture and your addictive
instinct to grab the phone
and ameliorate your you know your your
boredom yeah
by filling it with scrolling or whatever
it is that you look at on your phone
it's very difficult
it's never been more difficult to carve
out that time that fallow time yeah time
for rumination
and quietude and feeling wasteful i mean
yeah that's exactly it like am i wasting
time
by doing x or y or whatever and and
you know that's one thing that i think
uh adventuring which is what i consider
swimming and running these days for me
it's like it's like these mini
adventures
that allows me to clear my head in a way
that's a fallow time
within a day for me but it's not though
because i'm still trying to get
something done
so it really doesn't really qualify it's
about time it's hard
you know it is pushing my son and his
like new tricycle
is kind of but i also think it's the
mindset that you bring to whatever it is
that you're doing yeah
right like you could go out and and go
for a walk with your son
and and bring your phone and stare at
your phone the whole time or you leave
your phone at home
and right you comport yourself like
brogan
and go up and talk to people and live in
your brain and
you know kind of allow yourself to
mentally
meander yeah did we cover the period is
that periodization of your life
tell me about your life like periodizing
like where are you and your
periodization
journey and when's the what's this i'm
not great at it what's the most
successful you've ever been at it
well one thing i've done is to build in
this month every year
where i take off which is new i've done
it twice but i intend to do that every
year
i think travel for me is a is a is a big
aspect of that
in terms of rejuvenating me and and
exposing me to new people
in new places i find that to be very
nourishing
um like you're like you're co like your
big island
yeah yeah and when i went to when i went
to australia but even
you know when pre-coveted there'd be
speaking things and i would get to go to
all these cool places and
for me that's that like really reboots
my system so covid's been challenging
just to
be at home and sit with my thoughts and
i struggle with
adopting the appropriate healthy mindset
around
leveraging that appropriately but i
think at the same time
we have to be gentle on ourselves like
you know not to
not to kind of um beat a dead horse but
it's been a really hard year for
everybody and i think a fallow year
for everybody in a way that we wouldn't
have chosen or didn't expect
that's true so being gentle on ourselves
i think is
part of that idea of of periodizing your
life like this was a fallow year
rather live than regret
or frustration or resentment over it
while we're still kind of in it like how
can we develop a better
healthier mindset around
this experience how can we learn from it
how can we
use it for that kind of internal
journey that will help improve our lives
as we move forward in other
areas
[Music]
you